für die zuschauer ist es in dem fall
wichtig welche katastrophe man sich
widmen soll sie haben gesagt welche
katastrophe für sie wichtig ist für die
zuschauer ist im moment ganz greifbar
das was im portemonnaie passiert der
herbst der winter sie sagen herr bau ist
das ist ein realistisches szenario das
wir im blackout sogar ihr leben im
herbst und die zuschauer fragen sich was
passiert zum beispiel noch in den preis
muss sich jetzt geld zur seite legen wie
kann ich dafür dass ich möchte ich über
das sozial als schwerpunkt sind und ich
glaube wir werden nicht den strom
blackout bis zum herbst wie glas und
sonderling gas mangel blick auf es gibt
eine sehr interessante studie des
bundesverbandes für energiewirtschaft ev
vom 17 märz 2022 was die substitution
potenzial und einsparungspotenziale
aufzeigt wenn gas weniger kommt oder gar
nicht kommen es zeigt uns dass haushalte
maximal wenn geworben wird wenn wir alle
bürgerinnen bürger mitnehmen 10
eventuell 15 prozent einsparen dass wir
im industriebereich 4 bis vielleicht
zehn prozent einsparen können das
ergebnis war aber alle
einsparungspotenziale für
dienstleistungen handel verkehr und und
verkehr mit gas fahrzeugen machen
maximal betone maximal ein drittel der
gasmengen aus russland aus wenn russland
nur noch 40 prozent liefert oder gar
nichts liefert werden sämtliche
einsparungspotenziale
brutal arbeitsplätze kosten darum geht
es ja ich meine preise ist schon schlimm
genug aber was im augenblick überhaupt
nicht diskutiert wird übrigens auch
nicht von dem bundeswirtschaftsminister
der ja für die wirtschaft dieses landes
verantwortlich zählt er zeigt dass wir
möglicherweise mit sechs millionen
arbeitsplätzen sprechen müssen der
bruder müller von der basf sagt wenn ich
kein gas mehr kriege dann ist die basf
dicht in ludwigshafen und das bedeutet
für die gesamte chemie kette das
bedeutet kein glas erzeugung mehr das
geht weiter bis zu den
brötchen backen die ja auch nicht
geschützt sind sondern geschützt sind
der private haushalt und dafür werden
wir das gas auch haben die krankenhäuser
die öffentlichen einrichtung das wird
alles mit gas versorgt aber wir reden
über 50 prozent des gases die gehen in
arbeitsplätze und ich wundere mich
wirklich wie ruhig die gewerkschaft sich
das angucken was da im augenblick
passiert weil das was habe ich jetzt
macht und sagt wir geben mal so ein
bisschen kohle frei
weg den gas
den den gasverbrauch den wir im
kraftwerk haben nicht ab und da wir noch
eins sagt wenn sie dann noch am 31.12
drei kernkraftwerke abstellen die
immerhin
35 terawattstunden liefern die können
sie dann ja gar nicht mit kohle da
verdenken kohlekraftwerke haben sie
gerade wieder in die chance noch einmal
auf diesen blackout gedanken zu sprechen
kommen sie sagen brutale gefahr für die
arbeitsplätze in dem der situation muss
die regierung müssen auch sie abwägen
wem lässt man eigentlich noch das gas
und wem nicht im moment gilt die regel
die verbraucher sind versorgt es ist
schwer zu glauben dass das noch so
bleibt wenn die arbeitsplätze plötzlich
verloren gehen weil die industrie nicht
mehr produzieren kann und das in der
fläche können sie so eine garantie geben
oder wie werden sie so eine energie so
eine gastritis situationen dann lösen
wer bekommt das gas noch und wer nicht
wenn man erstmal seinen die situation in
der wir jetzt sind hat nicht die neue
regierung zuvor okay das haben wir schon
deswegen die entscheidung man hätte ja
jetzt übernehmen wir die regierung und
gucken uns an wie ist das eigentlich
bisher geregelt es ist gar nicht
geregelt man hat einfach nur gestrigen
und regeln als erstes abgeschaltet
haushalte müssen wir regeln wir regeln
ist so dass wir jetzt mit der gesamten
wirtschaft vor allem mit den großen
verbrauchern mehrere tausend mit denen
wir jetzt erstmalig ins gespräch
gekommen sind als regierung und dafür
sorgen dass wir wissen wo wird was
produziert was darf auf keinen fall vom
netz gehen weil es große schäden an den
produktionsanlagen gibt und in der folge
dann auch große volkswirtschaftliche
schäden mit arbeitsplatz das ist doch
eine hohe scheinende frage jetzt für die
richtige reihenfolge aber nochmal aber
war er hat ja ihre meinung der
hauptpunkt lautet wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir gar nicht in die
gasmenge lage kommen ja wir wissen aber
ich
frage sie treffen angeregt wir haben ihr
antwort ganz klar sagt ganz korrekt
weiter frage nicht beantwortet als
rekurse ich stelle die frage wie treffen
sie die abwägung und sie sagen wir
gucken wie wir die abwägung treffen so
nicht ohne liebe wegen sind die jetzt
millionen arbeitslosen ein soll fahren
heute stehen auch gestanden und unser
garten zu hause die heizung wird das
waren die entscheidenden von mir nicht
nur die richtigen fragen antwortet skoda
ist jetzt gesetzt was werden sie das
erste gesetz was wir durch den deutschen
bundestag gebracht haben ist dass wir
die gasspeicher befüllen die gasspeicher
in diesem jahr sei der winter im rahmen
bleibt und das ist gutes speicher sind
jetzt sofort dass man leider antwort auf
meine frage sie haben die latte ganz
hoch gelegt und jetzt muss die antwort
ja so ja ich der bundesnetzagentur dafür
dass wir genau wissen welches
unternehmen was produziert was auf
keinen fall rausgenommen werden darf und
dann gibt es eine ganz klare reihenfolge
von uns ja wie ist die reihenfolge da
sind wir doch gerade daran werden von
der bundesregierung dafür nichts
bekommen die bundesregierung davor weiß
nicht mal wie man eben auch zu hause
erfolgen das wissen welchen wir mit der
wirtschaft wir können doch jetzt als
politik nicht darüber entscheiden wer
abschalten soll wir sprechen mit der
wirtschaft habe das ja nicht
bisher saß der grundsatz die verbraucher
können sicher sein die haben eine
garantie die sind zuletzt daran vorher
wird die industrie abgeschaltet da hört
bei ihnen strauss gilt nicht mehr ich
möchte aber oder gar nicht durchzuhalten
ja ich möchte nochmal deutlich machen
der präsident
müller hatte ganz deutlich von der
bundesnetzagentur gesagt die letzten
tage wenn unsere gasspeicher voll
sondern es kommt eine notlage und
vielleicht wird in zwei zweieinhalb
monate würden die gasspeicher erreichen
wenn sie sich den notfahrplan gas
anschauen stellen sie fest dass auch die
geschützten kunden die bürger bezug
nimmt auf einen kalten winter
2011/2012 30 tage wahrscheinlich nur das
gas bekommen werden die speicher voll
sind und spezielle industrien vielleicht
für sieben tage wenn die speicher folgen
ich hab mir mal die derzeitigen
steigerungsraten angeschaut die liefen
haben pro tag in der vergangenheit bevor
putin darauf um 60 prozent reduziert
hatte um ein prozent 0,8 prozent derzeit
sind es 0,3 bis 0,4 prozent was machen
wir in wenigen wochen mitte juli werden
die nordstream 1 leitung aus reparatur
aber er komplett abgeschaltet die fläche
soweit antreiben muss man aus reparatur
gründen die dann vielleicht länger
dauern dann bekommen wir kein gas dann
werden wir auch nicht mehr ein speichern
können das heißt wir kommen nicht über
die 60 59 modellen diese frage für sich
beantworten also was müsst ihr in so
einem notfallplan drin stehen wie viele
arbeitslose würden sie in kauf nehmen
bis man den verbrauchern zu hause das
gas weg nennt ich würde kaum arbeitslose
in kauf nehmen wenn ich basf mir als
standort anschauen der gn40 bis 50.000
arbeitsplätze es ist eine stadt sofort
relativ schnell verloren verlustig wenn
50 prozent gas leistung nicht mehr es
schaffen aber das aktin wäre was wir
jetzt tun müssen ist jetzt schon gas
einsparen wir sind in einer perversen
situation die deutsche gas kraftwerke
laufen fast auf volllast weil wir stöhr
an frankreichs dass sie da die
atomkraftwerke in verhilft der kapuze
das ist wunderbar das sagt uns dass die
unterstützen wird gerade frankreich weil
die ihre kernkraftwerke nicht im glas
sagen uns jetzt sorgen wir als erst
jetzt hat die regierung hole kraft das
heißt bleiben ist live geschaltet es
läuft jetzt bei der regierung wie bei
corona da hat man uns auch immer gesagt
liegt jetzt in eurer hand wie schlimm
die krise ist einfach maske auf
ordentliches verhalten wie schön es ist
liegt bei euch an und jetzt läuft es in
der energiekrise wieder genauso dabei
hätte man möglicherweise einen hebel
erfahren wollt einfach atomkraftwerke
bisschen länger laufen lassen das würde
nicht alles helfen aber es wird den
schmerzen natürlich lindern aber ich
denke wir sehen auch wir müssen noch ein
bisschen weiter graben wir müssen sehen
dass über nur die jetzt abzustellen
kohlekraftwerke nicht abzustellen das
ist jetzt die diskussion ein wir müssen
auch über die reaktivierung der alten
reden in hamburg gibt es ein hoch
modernes kohlekraftwerk in moorburg es
hat ein 1600 megawatt das kann ich ihnen
gar nicht vorstellen was das bedeutet
wir müssen das alles im gasmarkt das ist
erstmal die erste frage und zweite frage
geht aber über den über den winter
hinaus du kannst natürlich auch nicht
den mitarbeitern sagen jetzt kommen wir
für drei monate wieder hier rein und
mach mal und dann bist du wieder nicht
gewollt weil wir haben ein völlig
negatives verhältnis zu fossilen quellen
und man könnte sie man könnte sie sauber
machen es hat eine technik gegeben co2
kraftwerke mit abscheidung mit co2
abscheidung dann haben sie ein sauberes
kohlekraftwerk und das hätte einen
großen effekt wir könnten die chinesen
sagen das macht ihr bitteschön auch und
das muss der nächste schritt sein
kohlekraftwerke
der in deutschland verbotenen ist
verboten obwohl der weltklimarat sagt
ihr müsst ccs des hauses das
sequestrierung ihr müsst ihr 2 ab
scheint aber nicht gemacht ist verboten
da sagt der weltklimarat zum beispiel
auch gerne ich müsste ihn sei es nicht
erklärt sagt der klima
hier so leitl weiter ich möchte aber
jetzt einmal einbeziehen in dieses
gespräch simone peter die mittlerweile
dem verband für erneuerbare energien
vorsitz die sie zu hause aber vor allen
dingen auch noch als grünen-vorsitzende
kennen schönen guten abend frau peter
die diskussion ist voll im gange hier im
studium und bei bild bei den richtigen
fragen und herfahren holt den sie
bestens kennen der hat gerade die frage
aufgeworfen nach der atomkraft das
müssen wir natürlich und nach der
kohlekraft ganz genauso aber erstmals
atomkraft frau peter sie vertreten den
bundesverband erneuerbare energien wie
man hitler hin noch einmal in der
schrift aussieht vertreten sie damit
auch die grüne energie der atomkraft
wenn ich so fragen darf
naja ich vertrete tatsächlich die grünen
denn den kindern dass es sonne wind
bioenergie wasserkraft und erdwärme die
atomkraft wird dieses jahr abgeschaltet
da sehe ich auch keine debatte mehr
gerade hat die woche der
rwe-vorstandsvorsitzende gesagt das ist
eine rückwärtsgewandte debatte wieder
haben wir die brandstelle und auch das
personal und es hilft uns wie eben auch
schon darunter gesagt ja gar nicht für
die versorgung von gas sondern es ist ja
ein stromlieferant und deswegen muss es
jetzt darum gehen und das sehe ich auch
irgendwo schadenfreude dass man einander
gemüt jetzt auch eine regierung dass man
überlegt wie kriegt man die gasmenge
zusammen und hilft nur bemüht nicht
darum dass man das elend jetzt
diversifiziert dass man andere quellen
sucht aber das wichtig ist dass anfangs
gesagt wurde wir müssen mit sonder- und
wind deutlich mehr ausbauen und den
überschuss zum beispiel auch grünen
wasserstoff zu bilden wir haben aber
auch potenziale bei der bioenergie denn
man kann gestern beschlossen dass sie
bis 2030 mit fossilen heizung rausgehen
also auch aus gas und den rest mit
bioenergie verfüttern und wir haben im
moment die silos bei den landwirten
folge wir haben etwa 9500 biogas lagen
die artrock zwei millionen haushalte mit
biogas sorgenkind da liegt auch ganz
viel hoffnung darauf peter die frage ist
nur trotzdem und sie können jetzt sagen
die debatte findet gar nicht mehr statt
die debatte läuft doch längst die
debatte läuft sogar in der
bundesregierung vor allen dingen durch
die fdp-minister befeuert die debatte um
eine verlängerung der atomkraft wenn da
noch ein bisschen ein teil zumindest der
lösung liegt wird nicht klar warum sich
die grünen dem weiter verschließen wo
warum auch sie sich dieser debatte wie
sie gerade gesagt haben verschließen
also zum beispiel atomkraftwerk isar 2
könnte man einfach verlängern sagt der
betreiber sogar selbst sagt einfach wir
könnten einfach so ohne dass es groß was
kostet einfach drei monate länger laufen
lassen das würde doch in der situation
total helfen alles andere wäre ja
unterlassene hilfeleistung im moment für
die verbraucher
ich hab es ja gerade versucht zu
erklären der strobe hilft uns hier nicht
mehr gas ansatz also wir haben im moment
situation dass darüber diskutiert dass
man kraft kohlekraftwerk in der sache
und ich war ja noch mal energieministern
im saal und ich weiß dass da für
kraftwerke der reserve sind die kann man
auch nutzen allerdings
das thema klima ist es eben angesprochen
worden dann müssen wir eben jetzt
schneller umstellt erneuerbare energien
bis zum jahr 2030 noch mal in der anlage
phase wenig kennt aber jetzt kurzfristig
müssen sie da können sie ein stück
beitragen und da sind ja auch die
brennelemente verwandten bei allen
atomkraftwerken
sehe ich weder den willen der betreiber
noch tatsächlich den nutzen und es geht
jetzt darum vor allem gas
bereitzustellen hier zu diversifizieren
und da kann ich nur sagen wenn man jetzt
auch zum beispiel bei der bioenergie
stärke wie das von abfallstoffen nutzen
würde die biomasse die auf grünland oder
biodiversitäts flächen anfällt benutzt
und eben die deckel in den gesang aber
auch eine möglichkeit aber es muss vor
allem darum gehen den gesamten
erneuerbaren
enix jetzt ganz schnell auszubauen
ja war noch ganz kurz zwischen täter
wenn ich da verfahren wollen über
überzeugt er erfahre ich ganz gern
einmal einmal das zwiegespräch zu lassen
frau peter erfahren heute überzeugt sie
dass das frau peter jetzt sagt na also
atomkraftwerke das hat ja mit dem strom
nichts zu tun das würde jetzt erstmal
mit blick auf die gaskrise vor allem
überhaupt nicht es ist natürlich völlig
falsch weil natürlich die abstellung von
ich sagte damals 35 terawattstunden
kohle kernkraftwerke bedeutet dass wir
gas kraftwerke hochfahren müssen und
dass wir mehr gas verbrennen müssen wenn
die kohlekraftwerke haben wir leider
nicht in dieser dimension wird zur
verfügung es ist einfach so es ist eine
ideologie man hat eine ideologische
position und ich sage mal voraus ich das
wird unvertretbar das wird die regierung
nicht durchhalten sie können nicht eine
gesamte nation so einsperren die
arbeitsplätze vernichten nur weil sie
ihre die ideologische grüne position wir
wollen möglichst schnell aus der
kernenergie raus auf recht erhalten das
wird nicht funktionieren
wir reden über eine verlängerung von 23
jahren bis wir diese krise vielleicht
bewältigt haben und wer dazu nicht
bereit ist der sag ich mal ganz offen
der gehört nicht in die bundesregierung
ganz ganz eindeutig sie müsse aber
respektieren dass wir unser eigenes gas
auch mal sehen was du nicht mehr davon
trotzdem der vorwurf trifft auch die
ideologie von herrn fahrenholz sie
sitzen immer noch einer ideologie auf
und sind nicht bereit alles zu tun damit
die verbraucher versorgt werden
also ich finde dass die macher von denen
in die debatte geworfen die sonst keine
argumente haben ich hab den rwe-chef
zitieren rwe vorstandsvorsitzender der
diese woche gesagt hat die debatte über
atom laufzeitverlängerung also ist
vorgestern so gequält ist
jetzt überlegen natürlich liefert kohle
strom und wärme und es geht darum gas zu
ersetzen da muss man doch einfach mal
die fakten zur kenntnis nehmen die
herfahren und nicht zur kenntnis nimmt
weil er sagt atomkraft würde jetzt etwas
tun es ist den leuten
okay jetzt in einem punkt der debatte wo
frau peter sagt der fan heute hält sich
an fakten erfahren holz sage ich dann zu
ende reden ja mache mache ich noch mal
ja wir haben einfach mit der atomkraft
gast wenige prozent dass er 35 prozent
die dann vielleicht noch mehr strom
liefern wir haben aber in das problem
einnahmeproblem wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass die haushalte und industrie
am jahresende genug wärme und genug gas
haben um die industriellen prozesse
nicht zu stoppen und ich zu
massenarbeitslosigkeit zu führen darum
geht das bemühen das ist der zentrale
punkt hilft uns die atomkraft niemals
nehmen weil sonst da sonst das
ideologisch sich auch eine scheindebatte
zu versteifen die uns aber gar nicht
hilft kraftwerken hält der situation ich
lebe selber an eine fahrmaschine die zum
beispiel die stahlindustrie im saarland
versorgt dort gegen kohlekraftwerke die
jetzt an lässt dann könnte die strom und
wärme liefern die atomkraft zu tun das
nicht das muss man einfach zur kenntnis
nehmen grüne die jetzt auf kohle setzen
aber sie sagen naja ideologische debatte
ist das nicht erfahren heute sagt doch
ist immer noch sie wollen die positionen
nicht räumen ihr wirtschaftsminister
grüner wirtschaftsminister sagte zählt
jede kilowattstunde sie sagen ist doch
ein paar kilowattstunden damit dem mit
der atomenergie aber machen wir einen
strich drunter wann wäre denn erfahren
heute hat ein gast der sendung gesagt
erfahren heute hat eingangs der sendung
frau peter gesagt dass erneuerbare
energien das ganze land darüber
versorgen können dass das wird nicht
funktionieren sie sagen hundert prozent
geht dann ginge das denn
also wir haben gerade der studie mit
zwei fraunhofer instituten gemacht ist
sagen die ist es realistisch dass die
bundesregierung 80 prozent des stroms
bis
20.30 100 prozent bis 2030 erreichen
will dafür müssen jetzt die
rahmenbedingungen und dem usv paket der
bundesregierung gestellt werden dadurch
dass wir immer mehr strom auch in den
anwendungen praktisch wärmepumpen oder
mobilität elektromobilität nutzen
schreibt nicht rum wir gehen trotzdem
muss man natürlich das hat eine farbe
hat anfangs zu recht gesagt wir müssen
im wärmebereich und jetzt muss ich auch
noch vorsorge treffen deswegen steht die
bioenergie oder auch die geothermie es
gibt jetzt gerade neue potenzialstudie
münchen versorgt er seine gesamte dame
zum beispiel beim remis dass wir da in
deutschland noch mehr potenzial haben
solarthermie müssen jetzt booster puck
aber aus dem weg gebracht werden damit
wären die nächsten jahr monaten nicht
hingenommen können für die nächsten
winter und dann sind wir der überzeugung
dass wir bis zur mitte des jahres dass
die
klimaneutralität aber auch mittel allen
sektoren und prozent erneuerbare
energien schafft mitte des jahrhunderts
nehmen wir mit finden sie den klima
protest auf den straßen wie eben den von
herrn jeschke eigentlich zur zeit
sinnvoll nützlich
da sehen sie ich kann die jungen
menschen gut verstehen die sich jetzt
wehren dagegen dass sie passte sich
möglicherweise keine zukunft mehr haben
wir haben vor wenigen wochen erlebt dass
in indien die vögel dehydriert also
ausgetrocknet vom himmel fallen namen
der letzten wochen erlebt dass spanien
frankreich deutschland unter extremer
hitze aber fehlt ist wird sich dafür auf
die straße zu kleben über die frage des
protests kann man sich sicher
unterhalten
im moment gut ausgeht und es geht auch
nicht darum die gesamte gesellschaft in
mithaftung zu nehmen aber die ungeduld
dass die politik jetzt gut steuern muss
von fossilen auf erneuerbare
energieträger und dass die
internationale
staatengemeinschaft jetzt handeln muss
und wirklich weg von den fossilen
energieträgern den unmut verstehe ich
okay du gehst frauen alex frei also eine
ex grüne die sagt aber wer kann man
streiten und trotzdem möchte solidarität
raus mit denen die sich auf die straße
kleben so wie es die
ja
die renitenten
die jungen leute nicht absehbaren sogar
noch erwachsen werden will ja ich auch
immer krise in den ausprägungen haben
wir genau ich habe auch kinder danke
frau peter herzlichen dank für das
gespräch